hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the chess olympiad
uh it is magnus carlsen versus george
meyer and i know what you guys are
thinking uh obviously norway is playing
germany but not really uh last time we
checked yes george meyer did represent
germany but he plays for uruguay now so
it is actually norway versus uruguay and
on board one magnus carlson versus
geraghmaier and you guys have been
requesting me to show uh the
classical ratings uh for quite some time
now and i don't know if i will be doing
this but when we are discussing magnus's
games as he is uh going for that 2900
classical rating i thought you know okay
it couldn't hurt uh will
i'll still consider it for for all the
other games but um uh you know uh
i i i see no harm in doing it uh as this
is a very very particular goal uh magnus
has set for himself so let's check it
out uh magnus has the white pieces and
he opens with e4
uh meyer prepared something very special
for magnus he plays e6 uh french defense
d4 uh we have d5 and now knight to c3 um
are putting more pressure on that d5
phone and the standard replies here are
bishop to b4 the winner variation and
also knight to f6 just putting more
pressure on the e4 pawn uh however here
we have d characters on e for the
exchange variation or the so-called
rubinstein variation knight captures an
e4 and now knight to d7 going for the
blackburn defense uh we have c3 by
magnus and now knight g2f6 bishop to d3
and now knight captures an e4 bishop
characters and the other knight takes
this knight's place knight to f6
attacking the bishop so bishop back to
c2 by magnus and now pawn to c5 um a
very very uh
modern modern approach to
this but it has been played before so of
course you will attack the center knight
to f3 and here uh we have a trade
captures captures and now bishop the c5
you might be thinking okay but can't we
just play e5 kick away tonight and then
trade queens not really because queen e2
and you didn't really trade anything you
just um you know
you're going to lose this pawn
so instead after knight captures on d4
we have bishop to c5 by meyer and now we
have castles by magnus bishop and the
four c characters and now uh there is a
game uh the disposition has been reached
before and the meyer has played it with
the black pieces and in that game bishop
the d7 was played however uh meyer uh
decides to mix it up as he is playing
against magnus obviously he knows that
magnus prepared for him he plays b6 it
is the absolute top move recommended by
the engine so meyer also shows that he
has an improvement on the game that he
already played and it is now as of move
12 that we have a completely new game so
uh queen to d3 uh magnus continues
development puts more pressure on this
diagonal so you have to be careful not
to j and not to just get checkmated uh
bishop to b7 and now bishop the a4 with
check and now the problem is you can't
really block this check you have to move
the king if you play something like
knight to d7 uh then d5 and how are you
getting out of this mess there's just
too much uh
pressure if you allow captures then
there's there will be a double attack on
the knight so you still cannot castle
and especially if you play bishop
captures on d5 which kind of is the
point of it all then comes queen to g3
attacks the g7 pawn and uh well
there's just no good move you can make
here again if your castle bishop h6 just
wins the game uh you can't play queen f6
to defend against checkmate because then
you hang the knight on d7 so it's it's a
terrible terrible position so here king
to a fade by meyer and now bishop to d2
magnus just continues development now
the bishop can
control either of these diagonals and it
will be very happy there so ponte h5 uh
you probably
are considering leaving your king on f8
or maybe just even playing king the g8
and then doing a nice rook lift here
going after the white king so uh king to
f8 can also be considered an attacking
maneuver by meyer so here rook ate the
c1 and now pawn to h4 now magnus doesn't
want to see pawn to h3 on the board so
he plays h3 himself and queen to d6 now
uh we have bishop back to d1 and now
rook to d8 putting more pressure on that
the d file and now magnus plays rook to
e1 it seems that magnus is offering the
d4 pawn but not really if queen captures
on d4 then magnus had in mind queen to
a3 with chicken once the king moves then
you move the queen queen to e3 and you
have full mobilization of your pieces
and the black still um well has has some
moves to make before
uh
fully fully mobilizing so uh the the
pawn will be captured just not right yet
first uh king the g8 by meyer and now
bishop to e3 so now magnus is defending
the pawn and knight to d5 putting
pressure on the bishop here uh queen to
d2 and here meyer just eliminates one of
the bishops so magnus is bereft of his
bishop pair so knight captures an e3 f
captures and now rook to h6 the rook is
now coming to g6 and denmark will have a
very very strong attack against
carlson's king so rook to f1 and rook to
g6 we have bishop to g4 now cutting off
the rook's attack to the uh gt pawn and
what happens if you play f5 that is the
real question here well that's exactly
what meyer played so we're gonna see f5
kicking away the bishop bishop to f3 of
course you have to play this and now
bishop captures an f3 rook characters
and rook to g3 now offering
a traitor works but also to mess up
white's pawn structure so queen to f2
adding a defender to the rook and now
pawn to e5 this is maybe a bit a bit
premature uh but meyer shows that he is
able to trade off everything so pawn to
e5 we have rook captures on f5 by magnus
e captures on d4 e captures and d4 and
not just queen captures on d4 sort of um
uh sort of sort of forcing a queen trade
but magnus shows that uh that's not
really the case magnus plays a rook to
f8 with check now you cannot capture the
rook uh queen would capture queen and
then it's game over so king to h7 and
now rook capture san diego forcing uh
meyer to capture back with the queen so
keeping the queens on the board queen
captures on the eight and now comes
queen to f5 with check um there was a
lot of talk about rook to c4 it does
seem like um a a very nice idea uh point
is that uh well how are you defending
against queen to see to check king goes
somewhere and then rook the c8 it just
uh
wins the black queen well the problem is
after king to g8 and queen to c2 now
threatening rook to see it there's queen
d3 and you really don't have all that
much to worry about
so
you you no longer control the the h7
square and rook the c8 check doesn't
really do anything so that that's why so
magnus instead goes queen to f5 check
with pawn to g6 now you could also block
with rook to g6 but that just looks
weird so instead pawn to g6 queen to f4
and now rook to d3 and now with ideas of
rook to d1 with check so rook to c7
check and rook to d7 this is the only
move if you don't play this you're just
dead lost so here rook captures queen
captures and finally magnus wins upon
queen captures on h4 with check so it's
a queen important game magnus is up upon
can he push for more than a draw here we
have king to g7 queen to f4 now uh
sort of uh centralizing the queen and
now preparing to bring the king into the
game and uh
well you you have to start pushing some
pawns otherwise there's no winning this
so queen d5 a nice centralizing move by
meyer going after the a2 pawn a3 and
pawn to b5 we have queen to c7 check
king h6 and queen captures on a7 magnus
grabs another pawn but now meyer has all
this activity with the queen and magnus
will have to give back some material so
queen d1 check king h2 and queen to d6
with check with king to h1 and now queen
to d2 putting pressure on the b2 pawn
magnus advances at pawn to b4 and now uh
queen to c1 would check king the g uh
not king to h2 if king to h2 then queen
to f4 so that's just uh
draw so queen to g1 blocking check to
keep the game going but that means also
giving back one pawn queen captures an
a3 and now queen to e1 defending his b
for pawn queen to d3 and now queen to h4
with check we have king g7 queen e7
check king to h6 and now king to h2 so
this is already moved 48 uh players did
uh reach a move 40 some eight eight
moves ago uh additional time with it was
um granted to them uh but uh uh
before reaching mu 40 i forgot to
mention meyer was a very very uh low on
time he was constantly under the one
minute mark one and a half minute mark
and uh he he played uh all the correct
moves to reach more 40. so here we have
queen to d4 and now pawn to h4 magnus
continues pushing uh queen to f4 with
check king to h3 and now queen to f5
with check king g3 queen to d5 and now
we have queen to c5 offering a queen
trade and it seems like you could trade
because black will also promote his pawn
to a queen the problem is that white
will checkmate first and this is the
problem characters can't respawn before
c6 b3 c7 b2 and once one brings the
queen into the game black also brings
the queen into the game there's queen to
h8 to checkmate so that's the problem
for meyer so after queen to c5 we have
queen back to d3 with check king to h2
and now queen to e4
uh we have queen to g5 with check uh
king h7 and now even pawn to h5 uh now
how how can meyer continue queen
captures on b4 this is the only a good
way to to continue queen captures on g6
king to h8 and now we have queen to f6
with check uh king h7 queen
king h7 queen to f5 check king to g8 and
now queen to e6 with check king h7 queen
f7 check kink the 88 and queen to f6
with check it doesn't seem like uh
there any progress will be made by
checking this black king so the only
progress that can be made is by pushing
these uh past
pawns so came to h7 and now king to h3
uh we have queen to e4 meyer again
centralizes and prepares to start
pushing his own pass pawn and ponte g4
we have queen e3 check and now king the
g2 you could also play king to h4
but
magnus first goes the other way around
and then he can block with queen to f2
so here queenie to check king to g3 we
have queen to e1 with check and queen to
f2 now queen to c3 check king to h4 and
now meyer also has these squares covered
so he can start pushing his pawn pawn to
b4
queen to f7 check king to h8 and now
queen to e8 with check king g7 queen e7
check king to h8 and now pawn to h6 now
meyer has to be very careful if he moves
the queen from this diagonal then queen
to g7 will be checkmate luckily he just
wants to push his past pawn so pawn to
b3 king to h5 and now pawn to b2 uh we
have queen e8 check king h7 now queen to
e4 with check king h8 and king to g6 now
covering all of these squares and
preparing to deliver checkmate or this
checkmate uh so b1 uh bishop uh not even
queen as it doesn't really matter uh
white will have to capture so getting
the queen off of such an active square
queen captures uh or no yeah he brought
a queen into the game i thought it would
be much cooler to bring a bishop but i
guess that that would be considered
maybe disrespecting the world champion
uh but okay yeah he brought the queen
into the game now comes queen captures
on b1 now queen to c6 with check and now
king to g5 we have queen to c5 with
check
queen to f5 blocking check and now comes
queen to e3 with check and this is the
last mistake on move 78 um
the the the way to hold this to a draw
and it's not easy there's only one move
that holds this to a draw uh i'm not
even gonna tell you what move it is feel
free to pause the video here and try to
figure out the only move that does not
lose the game for black here while i
give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
this incredibly difficult defensive idea
and for those of you just want to enjoy
the show the hidden resource is queen to
c7 that's how you hold this
because you you just have to keep an eye
on everything on all the checks on this
check
you have to keep an eye on the
on the g7 square always uh you have to
if for example king g6 threatening
checkmate you just kick the king back
queen to h7 check now king g5 you bring
the queen back queen to c7 and uh
believe it or not this is one of those
positions that you can memorize because
even though white is up two pawns uh
it's still a draw so uh you you will not
be sorry if you memorize this position
as it is so instead after queen to f5 a
queen to e3 check was played and this
will simply not do now magnus blocks
check queen to f4
and there is no more defense here uh
whatever you play you're getting
checkmated the queen to c5 check was
played magnus played king to g6 and he
was in this position on move 80 that
girl resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh so problem is uh you can't deliver
any more checks along the sixth rank uh
because after one check is given queen
f6 check forces a queen trait as it's
checked to the black king as well so
queen characters king captures and of
course you are winning king h6 you're
gonna push g5 and of course that's it
and another thing after king to g6 you
might think okay well what about queen
to c2 or something doesn't matter queen
to f5 and again there there is
no more
there's nothing you can do if you don't
cover this diagonal then we're just
going to play queen f6 check followed by
this checkmate or the instant checkmate
if you don't cover the back rank uh so
it doesn't really matter what you play
and the trading of course runs into
pretty much the same thing
so very nicely done by magnus uh meyer
did everything well uh he defended well
he played well he played very actively
he played the most interesting chess um
you know especially with the
uh with this um a very rare line of just
capturing any 4d captures any for night
characters and going for this blackburn
variation uh
very very actively and then even you
know bringing his king all the way to g8
so he can start attacking you it was a
beautiful beautiful uh
game uh but uh magnus uh magnus allowed
it he he wanted an active game just for
the mere possibility of of actually you
know uh getting some winning chances and
uh it did went his way his two eight six
four classical rating is now two eight
six six uh and we'll see if he can push
this even closer uh to 2900 by the end
of the olympiad
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to wish a
very happy 20th birthday to mitkins and
i would like to thank joshua figueroa
lintag richard nickerson alice ellison
silva and david kimura for contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it uh as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh
to cover the olympiad until it finishes
uh so thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day